[موسيقى]
طلعناها بنهايه العام المنصرم للي هي عم
بتقدم
للبرلمان اللبناني مقترح مراجعه لكافه
القوانين بقانون العقوبات اللبناني
وتحديدا
الفصل السابع من احكام قانون العقوبات للي
كانت تسمى رقم الاعتداء على الارض هي هيك
تسميتها بقانون العقوبات
عملنا مقترح هو اعاده صياغه مختلف المواد
بتبدا من اول شيء تغيير التسميه من جرائم
الاعتداء على العرض لا جرائم اعتداء جنسي
وتجديد العقوبه بوضعيات مختلفه لذلك كان
الشعار اللي هو لا عرض ولا عرض ولكن هي
جريمه ونحن مع اعتبارها جريمه كبرى ومع
تسديده
[موسيقى]
الازمه والدفع قدما بقضيه التجريم
الاعتداء الجنسي بهيك ظروف طبعا هي ملعقه
تحديات ومن هون كان اختيار ادوات بالحمله
والادوات
المختلفه كانت مكونات عم نحاول من خلالها
نوصل لمختلف الفئات والشرائح ونخاطب الناس
بظروفيه موجوده حاليا وين ما هن موجودين
ومن دون ما نكون كمان عم نضيف عبء
للانخراط بالحمله باعباء اضافيه
[موسيقى]
طلعنا الفكره مع التيم الكريتف كمان تبعها
ابعاده انه اعمل فيديو وانا عم بخبر قصه
بنت كانه قصتي لالي عم بقول انه ابن عمي
لاول لاول مره ست سنين عم بحكي القصه
كانها قصتي وبنص الفيديو وبرجع بقول انه
هيدي منا قصتي
ونشرنا هذا الفيديو على
وسارها ما بتتخيلي
كميه التفاعل اللي اجا على هذه البدايه
يعني ما صدقنا وصلنا اكثر من 13 الف رساله
عن نساء خاصه بالبلاد العربيه اكثريتهم عم
بيخبرونا قصتهم عم بخبروني قصه اختهم عم
بيخبروني قصه رفيقتهم وعم بيقولوا لي قد
ايه هيدا الموضوع بعده موضوع موضوع ما
بنحكي فيه قد ايه في نساء عم تمرق بهذه
الشغله
[موسيقى]
قاعدين قدامك وهن قوايا ما فيك تفرتي يعني
كنت كتير قويه ونسيت اكيد بكيت كزا مره
وتاثرت كتير بس كنت قويه
هن بيعطوك القوه بس ما رح كذب عليك دغري
وقت توقفنا هذه الكامبين باول ديسمبر
ورجعت على ورجعت كملت حياتي عادي ما كنت
منيحه يعني اخدتني حتى لهلا يعني بعدني عم
بعاني من كل هالتجربه
[موسيقى]
انا وقت البراند هيدا حكتني
وقرروا
بهذه الحمله صرت مقتنعه بعد اكثر انه ما
بدي وقف لحديت ما نخيل ما يكون في توعيه
يكفي لحد ما النساء
يبطلوا يخافوا يطلعوا يحكوا ولا من عيالهم
ولا من من اهاليهم ولا من المجتمع تبعهن
يلي هن اللي هو بذلهم ما خفت وما وقفت وما
راح واقف صراحه
[موسيقى]
عمليه تراكميه ولكن ايضا هي عمليه ايقازيه
بتكون احيانا للمجتمع لاضل مستذكر قضايا
بتمس بحياته اليوميه بكل لحظه
وايضا هي بتضلها تحافظ على نوع من
الحافزيه والامل بالتغيير كمان على نكون
عم نتفادى الموقف التشاؤم العام واللائم
العام
واستثمار
بطاقات البلد وتحفيز للطاقات الابداعيه